at 4 pm eastern time here on american
history tv on c-span 3.
a role in the vietnam war to a gathering
of policy makers vietnamese veterans and
war protesters
some 40 years after the fall of saigon
and america's withdrawal from vietnam he
called the 1975 evacuation one of the
saddest moments of his life but insisted
he had no regrets
kissinger sat down with lbj presidential
library director mark updegrove on the
first of a three-day conference in
austin texas that organizers called the
vietnam war summit then took questions
from the audience
we'll hear first from several
introductory speakers including
president johnson's two daughters linda
johnson rob and lucy baines johnson
the conversation with kissinger starts
in about 30 minutes this program is two
hours
please welcome mr david ferrio archivist
of the united states
mrs linda johnson robb daughter of
linden and lady bird johnson
the honorable hubertvo member of the
texas house of representatives and
vietnam immigrants
miss lucy baines johnson daughter of
linden and lady bird johnson
and dr bernard lefkey retired major
general of the united states army and a
silver star bronze star and purple heart
recipient
[Applause]
[Music]
the archive of this library contains
thousands of letters to our 36th
president many of which concern the
vietnam war
here are two letters from soldiers
stationed in vietnam during the height
of the press president johnson's tenure
in office
which reflect the dramatically
contrasting views of the war held by
americans including our troops
dear mr president
here's a picture of a little vietnamese
girl and myself
she has three older sisters two older
brothers and a younger brother
they live in a village about eight miles
southeast of danang
their mother was killed by the vc
because of us she is able to smile it is
our duty to keep that smile which
portrays so much on her face
but there are many more who do not have
the freedom smile which she has
it is our duty as americans to bring
happiness to those who may otherwise
never be as free of care as she
to be able to pose with her and have her
still look so happy gives the idea of
the good we are doing here
this is worth fighting for this is worth
dying for i know the weight you must
carry on your shoulder sir and i pray
that god will help you
i hope this letter and picture will
bring you a blessing
she says the marines are number one
sincerely yours
first corporal levern and venette u.s
marine corps
dear sir i hope this letter finds the
president in the best of health
before i begin allow me to introduce
myself i am pfc nichols united states
marines in vietnam and this is the topic
of the letter
like most of the servicemen fighting
here i don't fully understand this war
we're given training long talks and
finally a weapon and told we have a war
to fight so the people of vietnam can
have a communist free government in
short sir we're fighting this war for
the vietnamese people and i'd like to
know why
why should my buddies and other people's
sons have to die fighting for what he
doesn't understand or believe in
i've been here for seven months and
probably will be here until my 13
is completed if all goes well but never
will be able to understand
why are these americans and maybe myself
must die for people
who really don't seem to give a damn
most of us are hoping one day to see our
loved ones and to me this seems the most
important to most of us and if you were
to ask the question what are we fighting
for the honest men would tell you
to get through these 13 months to get
back home
i hope you can understand our feelings
and answer our questions in this letter
thank you sir for your time
the time you've taken to read this
letter yours truly pfc charles e nichols
united states marine corps
my i'm going to read two letters from my
husband who also was a marine in vietnam
and we got married in december in
washington and he left in march and uh
he came home on our daughter's six-month
birthday
this is may 31st 1968.
my darling linda today i was a very
lucky man about 11 o'clock this morning
i was back at the bunker the battalion
cp and walking toward the command bunker
when i heard the familiar sound incoming
mortars
even before the first round hit i yelled
incoming and dived for the nearest hole
just as the first round landed about 20
meters away
within 10 seconds other marines had
dived into the very same hole on top of
me which was only big enough for two
people to begin with
rounds continued to land all around us
for the next
minute or so then there was a pause of
about 30 seconds and one last round
landed right on the opposite edge of the
foxhole
fortunately all the shrapnel went
forward in the same direction the round
was headed and none of it came back into
the foxhole
as it was that one round which
completely destroyed the two company
office structures next to my office
and killed a small dog which was not
smart enough to get into a hole when the
incoming started
my office structure was only slightly
damaged and the only marine casualties
from that last round were the two mile
concussions suffered by
two men who piled in on top of me
had the round landed just six inches
shorter
all of us would have been killed
needless to say we all felt very lucky
even though there were a few others in
the general area who did not fare so
well
often chuck's company
provided security for
for the road sweeps and the convoys to
the outpost near the cambodian border
and this is an august 5th 1968 letter
i usually outpost the road all the way
out and then pick up the troops on tanks
and amtrak's on the way back otherwise
the round trip would take over a day
each way
we were a little past the half point
uh have that halfway point when one of
the amtraks was blown up by what we
later discovered was a command detonated
35 pound box line
command detonated means it was set off
by a person hiding some distance away
with a fuse box instead of a regular
pressure or pressure relief mechanism
it was immediately engulfed in flames as
the mine ignited at least six of the
amtrak's 12 gas tanks
i had one entire platoon on the vehicle
at the time in addition to a three-man
forward air control team and a four-man
amtrak crew
the net result was 30 casualties many
from shrapnel but all from burns
just yesterday i had received a fairly
large number of replacements and it
assigned over half of them to this
platoon to make up for previous losses
now they're back down to almost nothing
again for tomorrow's convoy i've already
made arrangements to borrow a platoon
from another company
someone is watching over me personally
because i was on the amtrak right behind
the one the enemy decided to blow up and
would have been just as good a target
fortunately the enemy didn't launch a
group attack a ground attack to go with
it i was very proud of the company again
when the chips are down they're
tremendous
this is a letter written to president
johnson by a captain of the republic of
vietnam army
winning from a u.s training base
in alabama on america's
109th birthday july 4th 1966
4th of july 1966
the honorable lyndon b johnson
president of the united states the white
house
dear mr president
i'm captain william tardang of vietnam
now under training at the u.s army
chemical school
and center
at fort mcclellan alabama
i am indebted and grateful to you
for your recently thoughtfulness
speeches
which made me
read over and over again u.s history
and its declaration of independence
again i found your speeches
the spirit of liberty which made america
strong and free
i am confident with the generous aids
and encouragement of your heroic nation
we shall finally emerge
victorious in the struggle for freedom
and independence
ankylos is a study i have tried to write
in english for the first time
i am taking the liberty to bring to your
attention
as a token of my appreciation
i sincerely hope
that it may express to you
our burning desire to fight for freedom
that almost
it may serve as a self-explanation
of a humble but grateful people who
truthfully show his weakness
to a true friend in order to be helped
more effectively
with my very best wishes and respect to
you
the leader of the free world
and to your honorable family may i
congratulate you mr president
on the occasion of your independence day
thank you
when patrick nugent and i met
the summer of
1965
he was graduating from college and
already a member of the air national
guard
we married a year later
with a dream reception in the white
house
our first child was nine months old in
april of 1968
when patrick volunteered for vietnam
patrick did not have to go
to war
he went because he wanted to serve his
country
like many wives of servicemen i
frequently went home to my parents
lying in my bed in the white house i
often heard the picketers say
hey hey lbj how many boys did you kill
today
i lived in the terror of knowing my
husband
and brothers in law
chuck robb
and jerry nugent might be one
of those boys
for my father
it was all
so very personal
three of our troops in vietnam
were family
all
felt like it
it was daddy's constant struggle to
bring them home safely and our country
to the peace table
in january of
1969 patrick wrote his father-in-law and
commander-in-chief a letter
my father shared it with me because he
was so proud of patrick
and grateful to him
his children and i
remain so
forever
12
january
my dear mr president
chuck and i had a very peaceful and
eventful christmas eve and christmas day
and da nang
the highlight of our yuletide season was
a telephone call from you mrs johnson
lucy
and linda
lynn made a strong effort to converse
with his daddy but the conversation was
one-sided all on his side
someday i look for him to be president
of a t that is
christmas day
chuck and i made three stops to
distribute the
articles he had gathered
our first stop was a small village some
30 miles southwest of da nang
where he passed out food and toys to the
villagers
we then went to the catholic orphanage
in da nang and handed out all sorts of
toys to the children
our final stop of the day was the naval
hospital in da nang where we visited
with the patients in the orthopedic ward
we also handed out writing materials and
fruit cake
christmas
1960
will always be a memorable one for two
reasons
number one
it was my first christmas
away from my family and i hope
the last and two
i was able to help other people
appreciate
the meaning
of christmas
the war activity has increased somewhat
since the beginning of the new year
everyone is half expecting some sort of
offensive around tech
the hot areas are still located
northwest of saigon along the cambodian
border
ten days ago my aircraft came under
mortar fire at khatum as we were coming
to a halt
on the runway
as usual i didn't realize that we were
being fired upon
my primary concern was to off load the
56 gi's i had on board
thank god
no one was hit
and the aircraft never
received
a scratch
the number of days i have remaining in
vietnam is diminishing quite rapidly
or as the gis refer to it
i'm getting short
as of this writing i have 88 days
remaining
i received my orders last week which in
effect state i am to report to bergstrom
air force base for separation from
active duty upon return stateside
this letter
will be my last
addressed to you as my commander in
chief
i consider it both an honor and a
privilege
to have served under your command
and direction
i didn't want to see you vacate the
presidency
since you are the best we have
but at the same time i respect your
decision and i am extremely proud of you
our men
in vietnam
know that you have done everything
in your power to bring about a peaceful
solution
to the war
unfortunately
we cannot negotiate
with ourselves
nor it is our desire to abandon the hope
of a free
and democratic
south
vietnam
you and mrs johnson
are in my prayers and thoughts today
and every day
love
pat
p.s
i enjoyed talking to everyone last night
thank you
and tonight it is indeed a tremendous
honor for me to speak to you
as we come together to honor our vietnam
veterans
and particularly those brave men and
women who sacrificed their lives
fighting for freedom
and democracy in vietnam
each year around this time on april 30th
vietnamese american communities
commemorate
and honor the fallen the fallen soldiers
we also remember and mourn the loss of
millions of lives in vietnam who died
seeking freedom
today on behalf of the vietnamese
american community i would like to
express
my deepest gratitude for the sacrifices
made by america during the vietnam war
58 000 brave american soldiers
and their families made the ultimate
sacrifice
which allowed
vietnamese american communities to
survive
and migrate to this great country
50 years ago
south vietnam stood in the fortress of
freedom and democracy
safeguarding against
the expansion of communism in indochina
in making the stand against communism 58
000 americans together
with 250 000 south vietnamese lost their
lives
north vietnam varying cause was to
prevent
foreign occupation
and ensure independent integrity
and over 450 000 north vietnamese
soldiers
died in the fight for that cause
today what can we say was achieved this
is great losses
why the communist states around the
world have already fallen
vietnam still remained a communist state
north vietnam primary objective of
preventing foreign occupation
has now turned vietnam
into a chinese vessel state
vietnam today still has neither freedom
nor democracy
what has transpired in the 41 years
since the war ended
does not change the gratitude we have
for the brave men and women of the
vietnam war is we honor them today
i mentioned these facts because to
probably honor those heroes
we must
examine
what their sacrifice means to us today
and how much the cost
of
for which they die still remain to be
achieved
one day
when vietnam is no longer under the
communist control
and is once a land of freedom and
democracy
the vietnam war will no longer be a
reminder of division
instead
it will be a reminder of a high price
that freedom requires in all great
countries
on that day
i believe that we will have finally
truly honored these fallen soldiers
and the souls of those brave men and
women
we'll be proud
that their sacrifice secure the most
important blessing for mankind freedom
[Music]
why am i here today
i'm here today because a young man
saved my life
and changed my life
in four years of combat
there were many soldiers
who did this
for many of us
the name
is larry morford
he was 24 when he was killed
15 days before coming home
this man
was in a battalion i commanded in 69 70.
in that area if you could remember it
was the height of the anti-vietnam war
larry
was a permanent christian
yet
he was one of the very few who
volunteered and the battalion i had over
90 percent were draftees he was one of
the very few volunteers
one day i asked larry
why if you're such a christian
are you here i know you don't believe in
combat
as the way to resolve conflict
and i know that you don't believe we
should be in vietnam
why are you here
his answer was simple
sir i could not stay home when others
were fighting this war
sir
also the job that you and i are doing is
the job of a beast
and the least beastly of us
should be doing it
that was sergeant morford's
message
he lived
his sermon
he's the man that has inspired me
to create an award every year at west
point the sergeant morford award that
sends west point cadets to china also
to teach preventive medicine in chinese
high school
he along with a corporal by the name of
lake fung
who was killed
at age 24
are two soldiers that are remembered
in china
we're trying to make
soldiers be role models of what a good
citizen should be
as cardinal spellman mentioned a
religious leader in the united states
he said it this way
if i had not been a priest
i most certainly would have been a
soldier
because they're both called to do the
same thing
protect the innocents and right the
injustice
i
listened to mark
our host
and he has given me a very strict
rule
and i must tell you that i left the army
and went to medical school and became a
missionary in africa and in africa the
rule is very simple
you can only speak as long as you have
one leg up
when you can no longer keep that leg up
you must give up the podium or the
audience can spear you
so let me end it by saying that it's
only fitting
that my
remembrance of sergeant larry morford
should be followed by sergeant henry
kissinger
because many of you probably don't know
that before dr kissinger became famous
he was a sergeant in the u.s army
may your parachutes open
[Applause]
so
so
ladies and gentlemen please welcome mr
larry temple chairman of the lyndon
banes-johnson foundation
as chairman of the lbj foundation it is
my privilege
to welcome you to this keynote
presentation
of the vietnam war summit
lyndon johnson would have been
very proud
of this summit and would wanted it to
take place
he would particularly have been proud
that the valor and commitment of the men
and women who served this country in
vietnam is being recognized and honored
here
while few people seek disagreement and
dispute
lyndon johnson never shied away from
controversy
when this library was dedicated lbj
famously proclaimed
it's all here
the story of our time with the bark off
there is no record of a mistake or of an
unpleasantness or a criticism
that is not included in the files here
the exhibits and papers in this library
certainly testify to the remarkable
accomplishments of lbj's legacy
his monumental successes and civil
rights
were chronicled in the summit programs
held in this library just two years ago
but this library does not ignore lbj's
anguish
the tragedy of the vietnam war his
greatest disappointment was the failure
to achieve peace in the war in vietnam
that he inherited and pursued
president johnson always wanted this
stage
to be the forum for the great issues of
the day
that includes reflections and revisiting
of events
of an earlier period
to learn lessons to apply to the current
time
so that is why i can say with certainty
that president johnson would welcome the
discussions of this summit
including
criticisms of decisions and actions
that were taken 50 years ago
to borrow president johnson's own words
the aspirations of this summit
is to revisit the entire story of
vietnam
with the bark off
there should be no record of a mistake
or an unpleasantness or a criticism
that is not included in this forum
now it is my pleasure to introduce lbj
foundation chairman emeritus tom johnson
who will present the program tonight
thank you larry
it is my honor and my privilege now to
introduce my friend
dr henry kissinger
dr kissinger and i have known each other
since 1967
when he was a relatively young professor
at harvard university
and i was a very low-ranking member of
president johnson's white house staff
in july
1967
dr kissinger was a top secret channel
for president johnson
through french intermediaries
with north vietnamese prime minister fam
van dong
and the aging ho chi minh
through dr kissinger president johnson
offered a bombing
halt if a cessation of bombing would
lead to productive
discussions between the united states
and hanoi
president johnson even proposed a direct
meeting
between dr kissinger and hanoi's
representatives
and as a good faith measure
president johnson unilaterally halted
bombing
in the vicinity
of hanoi
the north vietnamese response was
entirely negative
and i quote
we can neither receive mr kissinger nor
comment on the american views
as transmitted through this
channel
in a very highly classified meeting in
the cabinet room on october 18 1967
president johnson secretary of state
dean russ secretary of defense robert
mcnamara
and nsc adviser walt rusto asked dr
kissinger
to make
one more attempt
the north vietnamese response
and i quote
there is no reason
for us to talk again
what we soon learned was that hanoi was
planning a massive all-out assault
throughout vietnam
a sledge hammer blow
designed to shatter
the north vietnamese army
and
for them hopefully to drive the united
states out
on january 30 1968 hanoi launched its
tet offensive
it was much more massive
than the cia
or our military leadership had
anticipated
president johnson
and virtually all of us around him were
shocked
the north vietnamese and the viet cong
attacked 36
of vietnam's 42 provincial capitals
and five of its six largest cities
thousands were killed
but united states forces prevailed and
won
in every single battle
including a massive battle at way
despite his best efforts
and the efforts of the frenchman
immediately
the kissinger parish channel which was
code named philadelphia was killed as
well
in my opinion
no two men
so wanted an honorable peace
in vietnam
as did dr kissinger and president
johnson
lbj died before peace treaty was
negotiated
however dr kissinger and president nixon
did advise the president
president johnson at the ranch just a
few days before his death
that what they thought
would be an honorable peace agreement
was about to be signed
unfortunately the peace agreement dr
kissinger negotiated was violated by
hanoi and completely disregarded
within months of its signing
but the american people especially the
anti-war activists and we know that
there are many in this room tonight of
that era
anti-war activists everywhere especially
on american campuses
and the american congress
and the american press
had had all of the war
that it could take
united states troops
did not lose the war
they literally won
every engagement
however after eight long years most
americans had lost the will to fight
the price had become unacceptably high
in hanoi
ho chi minh and general jiap
never seemed to lose their will to
continue the war
until they had reunited
north and south
i know there are men and women in this
auditorium tonight who have disagreed
and continued to disagree
with henry kissier
yet i will assure you that he and lbj
also wanted peace
as much as they did
an honorable peace that would stop the
war
and permit the people of south vietnam
to remain free from communism from
repression
and from totalitarian rule
how
do i know
i know because i was there
i know because i took the notes
of their conversations
i read the transcripts of their
telephone calls
and their meetings
sometimes without doctor kissinger
knowing that i was on the line
i served as a confidential link between
dr kissinger and former president
johnson until president johnson died
they both wanted
an honorable peace
for his efforts dr kissinger won the
nobel prize
and after you see a brief presentation a
video of dr kissinger after he
negotiated that peace treaty we will
bring him forward
to introduce him to you thank you
[Applause]
the united states is seeking
a peace that heals
we have had many armistices in indochina
we want a peace
that will last
and therefore
it is our firm intention
in our relationship to the democratic
republic of vietnam
to move
from
hostility
to normalization
and from normalization
to
conciliation
and cooperation
and we
believe
that under conditions of peace
we can contribute throughout indochina
to a realization
of the humane aspirations of all the
peoples of indochina
and we will in that spirit
perform our traditional role
of helping people realize these
aspirations in peace
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
former secretary of state dr henry
kissner
[Music]
[Applause]
dr kushner welcome
it is a a privilege to have you on this
stage
uh one of the things i think most people
don't realize is that you are not only
the national security advisor to uh to
and secretary of state to to president
nixon and secretary of state to
president ford but also
a part-time consultant to president
kennedy and president johnson as as tom
johnson just uh just alluded to
so
more than any living person
i think you saw all the principal
commanders in chief around vietnam up
close can you talk about each of those
men and what characterized their
position
on the war
well first of all let me say
what an honor it is for me to be here
and to
participate in a conference
which is needed
to heal wounds
of the debates about vietnam
and so i want to congratulate the
library for organizing
this and
providing the opportunity
i'd like to say also that it's sort of
symbolic
that secretary kerry is coming here
tomorrow night
he was walking around with placards
outside the white house when i served
there
[Applause]
and
the point i want to make is
we've become good friends
in the interval
and he came to my 90th birthday party
and made a toast in which he said
he pointed out what he
what his actions had been then
and that it was a pity
that we didn't have an opportunity
to
to talk
rather than confront each other in that
period
in that spirit he and i have worked
together when he was
chairman of the foreign relations
committee
and i greatly respect his efforts now
and it's very meaningful too
that
this conference would end
with a speech by this distinguished
leader of america now
now to answer your question
in the kennedy administration
the
vietnam was at first a relatively
peripheral issue
the dominant concern
about indochina in the kennedy
administration
was the future of laos
and because they in turn had received
the advice
from president eisenhower
in the transition
that the future of laos
might determine the future of vietnam
then as
the administration went on
there was a
document that the chinese produced
by lin biao who was then a successor to
mao
who said that the whole world was going
to be characterized
by a struggle of the countryside against
the cities
and the kennedy administration tended to
interpret what was going on in indochina
as part of that process
but in those days we had only a few
thousand
advisers there but that number was
increased to about 50 000
in the kennedy administration
but it was not yet a central
obsession
of american for a policy
then
lyndon johnson
inherited a situation in which the
government of vietnam had been
overthrown
the north vietnamese
had infiltrated
regular divisions
and not just guerrilla forces
and so
as far as i could observe
lyndon johnson thought he was carrying
out
the spirit of the policy that had been
started by president kennedy
when he ordered the increase of
forces
and then
gradually
as the administration went on
a president who
all that life had been
known as concerned primarily with
domestic policy
was
engulfed in a division of the country
that
in a way has lasted to this day
in its perception of foreign policy
and i might say he
was
an anguished
person
because he wanted peace
and but his
notions of peace were
that
you made a compromise
and that is the one thing that the north
vietnamese
were never prepared to do
and indeed
i became involved
because
because the normal attempt to achieve
negotiations
had all been blocked
and i became involved in the following
way
i was at that time a professor of
harvard
with no standing
in the hierarchy in washington
and i went i attended a scientific
conference in europe
and at that conference there were two
individuals
who talked to me
because they knew i had
been in vietnam
for a few
weeks
earlier that year
at the invitation of ambassador lodge
well
one of these
two people
had been the host of ho chi minh
when ho chi minh lived in paris for a
year
to negotiate peace
with the friends
and he offered to go to vietnam and call
on his
acquaintance
on behalf of peace for the united states
i called up secretary mcnamara
to tell him about this
uh
secretary mcnamara
discussed the matter with
president johnson
and amazingly
president johnson entrusted
a
professor
at harvard
which was not the constituency that
most favored him
uh
uh
with being an intermediary
to two frenchmen that no one had ever
heard me heard of before
and
so they will send off with a message
from president johnson
to ho chi minh
that outlined the circumstances under
which he was prepared to
to make peace
and
they were received
by ho chi minh
and they came back with a reply
which after six years of negotiations
in various administrations we learned
was a typical north vietnamese
vague reply
that basically rejected the proposal but
made it sound
as if maybe there was something
so they brought back that reply
and i won't go through all the details
but i was sent back
with another uh message
and it not in none of this effort that i
ever see
a vietnamese negotiator
i dealt with the two frenchmen
they dealt with the vietnamese right
this went on for about three months
and then
after a while we realized that they were
that they were stalling
but i mentioned this only to show the
dedication
of president johnson
to achieve
a
honorable negotiated piece
from the very beginning
president dixon
had the problem of how
he inherited the war
there were already 500 plus thousand
troops in vietnam
and the question he had the same issue
as president johnson
how do you end
this war
and
how do you withdraw
these troops
without leading it to a collapse
of the whole structure in indochina
and as some of our allies
in the rest of south asia were telling
us
the collapse of the whole
structure you can ask me questions
about individual decisions
that were taken
and president ford was
president in the very last phase
of the war
but about him i want to say at the very
end
when the war
when it was obvious
and we were talking only about the
evacuation
of the last batch of civilians
that were stuck at the airport in
saigon
and i called them and
said we
it is now
has
that
we have to permit
the
evacuation
of saigon
and if you read that phone conversation
between him and me
he realized
that we had to
leave
but he wanted to squeeze out another 12
hours
to see whether we could rescue a few
more people
so
all the presidents were haunted
in
their way
each of them were dedicated to
coming with to finding a peaceful
solution
each of them had the dilemma
how you relate
american honor
to the ending of the war
and
that was
the dilemma
there was nobody who wanted war
there was nobody who wanted to escalate
the war
they all wanted peace
but the question was under what
conditions can you do that
without turning over the
maybe
millions
who in reliance on the word
of previous presidents
had committed themselves
uh dr let me go back to john f kennedy
uh there is widespread speculation that
had he not been assassinated president
kennedy would have reversed course
and withdrawn troops from vietnam
despite any evidence
to that end is there anything you saw
from president kennedy that would
suggest that over time he would have
withdrawn
our support for the war in vietnam
i never seen the slightest evidence of
this
it is possible to say that he might
would have done this
but
all the moves of the kennedy
administration
while kennedy was alive
were in the direction of increasing our
commitment right and not diminishing it
all based on the belief
that it was a simpler problem
than it turned out to be
but i have never seen a piece of paper
and that would indicate this and
all of the chief advisers
of president kennedy
who were taken
over by president johnson
when he became president
the unanimous
right in both presidencies
in supporting the courts that was
adopted
until things got very difficult
and then of course divisions appeared
right but i have never seen them
i i know no evidence that president
kennedy would have done that yeah
uh
linda johnson is
was a domestic policy sage
uh he knew how to get deals done he knew
instinctively what to do
there are many who think he was out of
his depth
in terms of foreign policy
what is your view of johnson
as a foreign policy president
well
president johnson was
saddled
with the war from the first day in
office
so
you can't really judge what
the foreign policy
tendencies of a president
who was
swallowed up in a way
by by the war in vietnam
without any question
johnson was a master in
knowing the nuances of domestic policy
and he did not know the foreign leaders
as well
as he did the domestic constituencies
and so
it didn't come as naturally to him
as it
did in domestic policy
but on the foreign policy issues other
than the war in vietnam
he had a
very
good relationship with our allies
and
our enemies
he was very eager to come to some
agreement with the soviet union
but everything was so overlaid
by the war in vietnam
i thought president johnson
was a formidable individual
of in some ways
it was a personal tragedy
that he spent
so much of his life
to achieve that office
in order to be impelled to do the things
that had not been his major focus
but i thought he was a strong figure
and i i felt
great respect and affection yeah
it has long been alleged that richard
nixon's presidential campaign in 1968
tampered with the peace process
by sending an emissary and anna
chennault to the south vietnamese to
urge them to withhold from negotiations
with the north vietnamese because they
might get a better deal from a president
nixon
what is your view of that dr kissinger
well
i have no personal knowledge of
whether that contract
actually took place in the way
it has been alleged
but assuming that the story is
essentially
correct
i do not
believe that it had
that whatever nixon did
had any of the consequences
that
that have been alleged
you have to remember
this aspect of our relationship with the
vietnamese
the vietnamese
of vietnamese allies
were always in a nearly desperate
position
they needed our help
it's as an essential component
so when a peace process was going on
they had a tendency to agree
to provisions we put forward
on the theory that the north vietnamese
would always reject them right
so
in 68
we experienced
what nixon then experienced
four years later
that when the point came
actually to undertake the negotiations
and they would have to assume
responsibility
for the outcome
that then
the south vietnamese leaders felt
it necessary to demonstrate to their own
people
that they hadn't just been forced by the
united states
to do this
and so
they had started
a
debate
about something
that
i'm sure president johnson
in his day and i know president nixon
in our period
thought had already been settled right
so
one of the key issues was
actually to sit down at the
table
and that of course then produced the
necessity for the south vietnamese
to sit down at the same table with the
people
who had been fighting to overthrow them
from the south of vietnamese
communist side
and so when that issue
arose as a consequence of the
negotiation
president jude dug in
and they started a
debate
about
the
way
the negotiation could even start right
we faced exactly the same thing in a
different way
four years later
we made a
tentative agreement with the south with
the
north vietnamese
and we thought that south vietnamese had
agreed to each of the
terms when we had discussed them
but then when
they were actually put forth
were put forward
we went through
six weeks
of controversy
about nuances and details
so that was inherent that would have
happened
where the next wrote its note on a
second line
so you can
so some delay between the announcement
and the sitting down
was in my opinion inevitable right and
not called by the nixon letter but
there's one other thing to remember in
the public debate it is often alleged
that peace could have been made
if somehow they had all sat at the same
table
there was absolutely no chance of this
whatsoever
because on november third two days after
these announcements were made
the vietnamese published their
conditions
which they never changed
for the rest of the johnson
administration
and for the leads of the nixon
administration which were
the united states had to withdraw
totally
and form a coalition government
dominated by communists
before any negotiation could take place
about anything else
so
uh
the
charleston administration official
position
at that time
was published position that the
vietnamese north vietnamese had to
withdraw
before any withdrawal of americans could
even
take place
so
those conditions were maintained for the
rest of the johnson administration
and they were the old principal obstacle
to the failure of
the negotiations in the nixon
administration
until the
vietnamese were defeated
in
the sequel to the ted offensive right
that tom johnson
mentioned
the one thing that the nixon
administration would not concede
is that we would that we would overthrow
an allied government
that had
supported the united states
in reliance on promises made
by other
presidents
and as soon as the north vietnamese
agreed
that the
existing government could stay
which was at the very end of the next
administration
a settlement was achieved and i
mentioned it only
because america should not torture
itself
on the view
that it could have had
a settlement earlier
if their president had been more willing
they could not have had a settlement
except for just
selling out and withdrawing
unconditionally which nobody
would have supported
there was a bob haldeman
president nixon's chief of staff set in
1978 television interview nixon had no
intention of quickly pulling out of
vietnam
he aimed to exploit the rivalry between
china and the soviet union to improve
relations with both of them
vietnam was an expedient where america's
bonafides our intentions our motives
were being acted out
nixon believed that america had to
negotiate from strength to prove its
willingness to fight
vietnam became that place
how does how do you respond to that does
that characterize in your view
nixon's position on the war
that characterizes part of nixon's
position in the war
this can be interpreted
by professional critics of it of nixon
to mean
that he fought so that he could do some
other things
that was not what he thought
he thought that if america discredited
itself
by abandoning its commitments in vietnam
he could not do the bigger things
that were needed
in
in order to make the war in vietnam
fit into a global perspective
and
so in
the sense that he said this is not only
about vietnam
but this is about trying to create a
world order
in which
vietnam
can no longer occur
in that sense it's goody right
you you uh say in your book ending the
vietnam war that the domino theory was
real
the domino effect would have played out
what would have been the consequences of
not waging a fight in vietnam in your
opinion look
the problem of
any foreign policy decision
is that you have to make it on the basis
of assessment
you cannot prove true when you make them
that they depend on a judgment
and you can always come up with a
counter factual
argument
a
person
who had a great influence
on
our thinking
and i believe also to some extent on
president trump's thinking certainly on
ours
was prime minister lee kuan yew from
singapore
one of the great men that
i have met
he
inherited a sandbar
with a per capita income of hundred
dollars
and turned it in 20 years
into a significant country
with a per capita income of 55 000
without any natural resources
based on the
dedication and quality
of the
of of its population
he was convinced
and so we have many others
that if vietnam collapsed
at the time that president kennedy and
johnson made that decision
that then the whole south asia
would be
would be engulfed
and that the same thing would then
happen in indonesia malaysia and
elsewhere
and he maintained that opinion until his
his
death
and he was not a cold warrior in the
abstract
he was a judge
of what it took
to keep his little country
secure
uh
do you agree i believe it i agree with
that yeah and
yes so i think
that the presidents who made the
major decisions
uh had a reason for making them yeah
in his 2015 book the last of the
president's men
bob woodward writes of a january 1972
memo that you wrote to president nixon
updating him on the military situation
in laos
president nixon wrote a handwritten note
on that same
memo
which read k meaning kissinger
we have had 10 years of total control in
the air in laos and vietnam
the result equals zilch
there is something wrong with the
strategy or the air force
and yet the night before
in a cbs interview with dan rather
president nixon said of the bombing the
results have been very very effective i
think their effectiveness will be
demonstrated
publicly
president nixon is saying the bombing is
effective privately to you
he's saying that they have done zilch
how do you account for that he was
saying that
it's very
one of the curses
of
modern activism
is
that every scrap of paper
gets collected
and it's then treated as if it were a
legal document
here are these the presidents
they work
18 hours a day they're under
constant pressure
and they write a note to their advisor
in frustration
that it's still
going on
and
nixon had a way
of
exaggerating
its comments
i can tell you here what
when uh
woodward called me up with this yeah and
he
he said
what did you do when you received it
i said
i did nothing
and
he couldn't believe it
why would i do nothing
because i had worked with president
nixon
for ten years
or eight years
and
when it when you got a message like this
i had a tendency
after a while
to wait to see
whether there'd be a follow-up
and
and if you think about it
that is would be the normal
way
uh
you i mean
on the worst assessment of the air
campaign
you cannot possibly say that it achieved
nothing
it you can say it may not have achieved
everything that
uh that he wanted and you'd have to
break it down and what the
various components uh
were
and i think probably
nixon
might have slightly exaggerated
what he said publicly
and he surely exaggerated his
frustration in a handwritten note right
uh
probably written late at night
and
and
and i think
one ought to analyze these documents
that are floating around
from that point of view
i mean what was the context
in which the comment was made
but you had to nixon is a very
uh enigmatic
person uh and you write often that he
would say one thing and mean another so
you had to judge
when
he was saying
it didn't mean and i would
i had a
very clear idea
of what he wanted
and you have to understand you cannot
survive
a security advisor
you have only one constituent
that's the president of the united
states right
and you must be absolutely straight with
him
and the
most important thing a security advisor
can do
and must do
is to tell the president the options
he has
sometimes he has to save the president
from
ill-considered first
moves
and if
you abuse that
your
utility
is it's
it's internet
so nixon
it's now
generally known
hated
personal confrontation right
and so therefore it fades to fade's
confrontations
it was like it was possible
that he expressed himself
ambiguously
but
if you
in any written exchange
you could absolutely rely on what he
was saying
and if you look at his record
he knew
he was a very strong president
in sticking to his basic convictions
and he took
enormously difficult decisions
and there was no ambiguity about
them but it was better to discuss them
with him
in
writing
than as a face-to-face confrontation
and
one will find in going through the
archives which are now available
that
most of the key decisions
when i was security advisor
were based on memoranda
and not on
conversations
the conversations played a very
important role
in the creating the mood
and establishing the
general context
but when a precise decision was needed
it was best to do it in writing
but i think it's a good way anyway
in relations between presidents
and techy people right
uh tom johnson mentioned your commitment
to the peace process and the fact that
you in 1973 along with your north
vietnamese counterpart lee duct toe won
the
nobel peace prize
uh there are many who allege that you
are a war criminal due to the systematic
carpet bombing of laos and cambodia
why was that bombing necessary to
our strategy in winning the war
well you know
by now i'm
in my 90s so i
i've heard it's
sure
i think the word war criminal
should not be thrown around in the
domestic debate
it's a shameful it's a
reflection on the people who use it
let us look what was the situation
first there was no carpet bombing
so that is absolute none is not true
what the situation was as follows
in the johnson administration
the north vietnamese moved
four divisions
into the border areas of vietnam
and cambodia on cambodian soil
and established page areas
from which they launched attacks
into
into vietnam
and these
divisions were put there
in opposition
to the uh to the local to the
to the cambodian
government
in fact the cambodian government told
chester bolt
who would say as a representative of lbj
that if we bombed those areas
and didn't kill any cambodians
that they
would close their eyes to it the lbj
administration decided
not to do this because they were already
under
pressure domestically
and for many other reasons that don
johnson may know
better than i do
but then
the
when nixon came in
uh nixon had already
touched before he assumed office
sent a message to the north vietnamese
that he was eager to resume
negotiations
in the third week of the nixon
presidency
they started an
offensive
in which every week
500 up to 500 americans were killed
and many of these attacks
more than half of these attacks
came from the
areas
that were
occupied
by those four divisions
inside
cambodian territory
and
after we had
suffered
1500 casualties
nearly as many as we suffered in 10
years of war
in afghanistan
nixon
ordered
an attack on the base areas
within five miles of the vietnamese
border
that were essentially unpopulated
so when the
phrase carpet bombing is used
it is
i think in in the sides of the attacks
probably much less than what the obama
administration
has done in similar base areas
in pakistan
which i think it's justified
and therefore i believe that what was
done in cambodia
was
justified
and when we eventually wiped out the
base areas
the casualties
went down by 80 percent
and
so
those were the decisions
and i would bet
that sooner or later
any president would have had to do it
because this is one that if you fight a
guerrilla war
and permit pace areas
from which
the
the killing units of the guerrillas are
unsustained
then you are in an absolutely
hopeless position
yeah
those
was security advisor i strongly favored
it
but i was not because i was at such come
in
but it doesn't matter i'm certainly
strongly supportive of it it was correct
and it was in the american
interest
and
the civilian
casualties
from this bombing along the five mile
streak
is
what's justified
we have to ask ourselves another thing
the argument against doing it was
that cambodia was a neutral country
but
a country that had four divisions on
energy soil
it's not actually a neutral country
and
and the leader of cambodia prince
hernock
told the johnson administration
that
he would
in a way welcome this
bombing
when we then actually did it
there were
press inquiries
and he told said in a press conference
i don't know what goes on in the part of
my country
in which
no cambodians live
and which is occupied by the vietnamese
if any
cambodian is killed
or even a bullock gets killed
i will protest
he will he never protest
toward the end of his life robert
mcnamara stood on the stage after
publishing a book and expressed regret
over the war and how it was waged he
said that the war was
futile
and that his conduct was wrong comma
terribly wrong
um
have you any regrets on any of the
actions that you took in vietnam
no
we took but you always make
tactical mistakes
uh
i believe that the
american presidents
and those of us who worked with them
were acting on the basis of their best
judgment
at the time
and
i uh
i think
we they were
mistakes were made
and some different in the cause of
discussing
the vietnam war i want to discuss
how one can
can
learn from these
but i uh
i'm proud of
the service
um
and i must say
uh
bob mcnamara was a
really good friend of mine
and i have huge regard for him
but one should not tell
what
seem to me
after
one should stand by one's decisions
right
what is the biggest lesson we should
draw from the war in vietnam dr kister
the biggest legend
is
not just from the war in vietnam
i would say the
dilemma of american foreign policy in
general is this
we have left behind
two great oceans
and a lucky part of the country has
lived in the center part of the country
where the consciousness of foreign
dangers
inherently could not develop
in the same way it had to in asia and
europe where peoples are being bred
together
so therefore americans have a tendency
to think
that peace is the normal condition
among people among countries
and when there is war
or when there is
instability
it is
sort of an accident it is sort of an
unusual condition
which you can remedy by one set of
actions
after which you can go back
to a condition of great stability
but most
deep international problems
are caused by
circumstances
that have a very long time to develop so
to answer your question
we clearly
uh we we've been involved in five wars
since world war two
which we in effect lost
we ended each of these wars
with a wide public consensus
there was an 80
support
for every one of these initial action
but then
after some
period of time
then people say we have to end it
and you need an extrication strategy
well
the best extrication strategy is just to
get out
but you can also call that defeat
so
if you
enter a war
you should not do it for objectives that
you can sustain
and if you cannot describe objectives
that you can sustain
you shouldn't enter it
secondly you have to distinguish
you i mean as a country
between those things
you
will do only if you have allies
and those you must do
because your national security requires
it
regardless of whether you have allies or
not
so
you have to make that distinction
and we have to learn and this is i would
apply this criticism
to almost all administrations
not to to not to get into
these conflicts
unless you can describe an aim
that you're willing to sustain
and unless you are willing in the
extreme
to sustain it alone
or to know
when you have to end it
those are lessons
you have to learn also from vietnam
and
and
but
we also have to learn
to moderate our domestic debate
because in the course of the vietnam war
what started as a reasonable debate
about whether we were engaged in a
process
that we could master
was transformed into an attack
on the moral quality of
american leadership
and when one teaches it people that it's
basically patriotic
for 20 years that they are run by
criminals and
unfolds
then you
you can get a politic
debate
that becomes more and more violent
and we suffer from it in some of our
current
political debate
that is one legend we should draw
from from the vietnam war
which also means we should moderate
the arguments
but make them deeper
based on that
view
uh how would you assess the war in iraq
well
first of all i
ultimately i supported it
uh
uh
i had mined a different kind of who i
thought we would withdraw after saturn
was overthrown i thought more of
the push one type of war
we failed to make
in iraq
and maybe in syria
that we made fail to make
this aspect that analysis
which goes back to my original poet
namely
we look at these countries as if they
were one unit right
and then we see a ruler
that is
oppressive
and we say let's get rid of this ruler
and then the people of iraq
or the people of syria
have a democratic government
and can restore stability
but what has happened in iraq and in
syria was
at the end of world war one
the european victors
organized
a group of
tribes
religions
ethnic entities
one of them
was syria
that had a majority of sunnis
and a minority of shia
which in syria are called alawites
and in iraq it was the opposite
it had a minority of sunnis
and the majority of shias
so in each case
the american president said
let's get rid of the
top guy and we will have stability
but getting rid of the top guy
produces a conflict
among the various minority groups
who are then fighting for preeminence
and so we have to learn
that
that
when we get into an ancient building
and then we
in such a war we have to engage in
nation building
and so
i think we did not understand
the complexities of nation building at
the general proposition in several
administrations right
that's how i would have said
the war in iraq we cut into something
deeper
than we assessed
at the beginning
dr kissinger has graciously consented to
take a few questions from the audience
and i will
ask him another question as you
uh who wish to ask questions queue up
behind the microphones that are on
either of the aisles i ask
please that you
uh ensure that your question is in fact
that a question and not a statement and
that you be
uh
as brief as possible in
asking that question dr let me uh
it's impossible to ignore
the election as it plays out you said in
a 2014
interview with scott simon of national
public radio
that you think
hillary clinton would make a good
president but you intended to support
the republican nominee
i i'm not going to get into the
[Applause]
is it
is it fair to say dr that that that 2014
was a long time ago
um
are you still inclined to support
whoever the republican
party nominates
i haven't made any pronouncements fair
enough
i if i might add you would
kind enough to say i consented to answer
questions
i insisted
on answering questions you insisted
uh i wanted to give the audience
i must say to dr kissinger's everlasting
credit he called me
several weeks ago and said
i want to take questions from the
audience i'll take any question that
they offer to me i ask that you uh ask a
question again briefly
and
in a civil manner and we'll start with
this gentleman on the left
dr kessinger
when
the accord was signed in laos in 1962.
uh
they
they counted on the vietnamese to honor
the honor the neutralization of laws
which didn't happen and they they did
not acknowledge that that accord was
broken
in your agreement
you had a side aside expectation
of
the north vietnamese moving their troops
out of cambodia laos and that didn't
happen as as you as expected by the
negotiators
how do we fight that
well
at the same proposition you can say
at least until recently
the north vietnamese
must hold the olympic record for
breaking
agreements
the 1962 agreement uh on laos
uh
if you
generalized president eisenhower
was convinced
that laos was the key to vietnam
that if one believed that vietnam was
important
to the security of the united states
then one had to keep laods from falling
under north vietnamese
domination
and he is
reported and i believe did
recommend to the incoming
administration
that they should make an issue of laos
and seem to imply that he would favor
even using
some american troops to achieve this
allowed being a less complex country
in which to achieve this objective
the
kennedy administration
was not willing to put in forces
but it threatened that it might
and as a result there was a
neutralization agreement
and that was broken by the north
vietnamese almost immediately
and they turned clouds into a
into a
supply base
and all the supply routes
most of the supply routes went through
laos
in 1972
when
the nixon administration made its
agreements
we had
a lot of practice in
violated north vietnamese agreements
the
but we were faced
with the near certainty
that the congress would vote
an end to the war
no matter what
what action
would be taken
and secondly we believed
that the provisions of the vietnam
agreement if we could enforce them
would also protect the other two
countries
we thought that the
south vietnamese forces that existed
could withstand all but an all-out
attack
and we would have enforced or we meant
to enforce the agreement
if there was an all-out attack
then watergate
destroyed that possibility
and then the congress
legislated
a prohibition against any attempt to
enforce the agreement
and so
so we will not know
uh
what might have happened but you're
right it
by the time that these agreements were
made
in 1972
the american domestic position that is
integrated
to a point where
those were the best terms that were
available
and it goes back to the point i made
earlier
we must
in
if we
end awards
also make sure that the domestic page
for it
can be sustained
that's important responsibility of the
administration
but the opponents also have to
understand
that if they think
if they achieve their objectives
by undermining all confidence in
government
then
of course no strategy can succeed
yes ma'am thank you my name is jeannie
with voice of vietnamese americans dr
kissinger is it is widespread that you
have toxically agreed to arrange for
china to take over the paracels island
in 1974
on whose behalf did you do so
and given the current south china sea
situation and other concerns in asia and
indo-pacific ocean
what advice would you give president xi
president obama and our secretary kerry
thank you
i'm not sure have fully understood the
question if it's the question
that we tacitly that we agreed
in said 1974 that china
could take over so i'm not quite sure i
understand restate the question if you
would very briefly yes it was understood
that
the u.s under your supervisor as a
secretary of the security advisor
had arranged so that china
could take over the paracel islands in
1974
so that we don't lose that area to
russia
now today
what would you suggest us do
on behalf of the national security of
the u.s
and given all the attacks that china is
doing on the us on all fronts do you
think that the agreement that you signed
with mao and luth
mao in
71
1972-71
and all that time
is worthy of our 58 000 deaths of the
american soldiers thank you
well first of all
for the
benefit of
the two or three non-texas graduates
here who may not
who may not know what the paratel
islands are
those
the paracel islands
it's a group of islands
in the south china sea
located
between china and
vietnam
and
uh
depending on from which point of land
you measure the distance
they're either closer to vietnam than to
china
it's anyway a disputed
issue
the chinese claim these islands because
hundreds of years ago a chinese emperor
drew a line in the pacific
near the philippines and he said
everything on that side
belongs to
china so and
chiang kai-tech already claimed these
islands
the vietnamese
also claimed
claimed these islands
at the american position with respect to
the islands
has been
consistently
that we do not take a position
on the sovereignty
of these islands
in 1974
in the midst of
watergate a war in the middle east
i can assure you
the paracel islands were not foremost
on our mind
but
there is no agreement that was ever
signed
in which we
gave
china a right to
occupy the paratel islands
nor have the chinese ever claimed that
and so
i think you're you're not well informed
the
there was no specific negotiation
maybe thank you ma'am what was that yes
sir your question
mr kissinger
i was a south vietnamese soldier
who spent
10 years in communist prison
thanks to the very agreement that you
signed
with hanoi in 1973
47 years ago you forced
you are sure my presidential that you
would support you would end up you will
send troops to help our nation our
country to def to defeat
the north vietnamese if they invade
vietnam but you did nothing and the
result is that vietnam for the communist
hanoi
and i expect that you should answer the
question
what we learned from vietnam war that we
would never betray any ally that depends
on earth and trust us very much thank
you
i
have great sympathy
for these questions from the from
vietnamese
they had a right to think
that
we had promised them
support
through
a number of administrations
including the one in which i served
when vietnam was collapsing
it was
impossible to convince the countries
to pass any additional
funds
we're talking now about 1975.
there were 35 other nations
that had signed
on
to the agreement
when it was made in 1973
we appealed to all of them
and none of them was willing to act
it was one of the saddest moments
of my life
and all of our super
and
the day
that of the evacuation of saigon
was one of the saddest moments
of my life and of all of us
who had been
had seen
the dedication of vietnamese
the dedication of those
people who served there
a little of which you heard in the
letters
that the two
children read
i have sympathy for your question
and i hope no other american
leader of its time
gets
asked similar questions
but the fundamental failure
was the division in our country
without that we could have managed it
yes sir
do you know how to turn it on or is it
is it working now okay there you go i
don't need it
he just identified himself i think
infantry i-corps vietnam 68-69
after the tet offensive
after lbj refusing to run again after
walter cronkite
there was peace with honor as a striving
yet it cost tens of thousands of
casualties
would it have been better to skip the
honor and dodge so many of the
casualties
getting out earlier
but it should
given the fact that peace with honor was
took such a toll
uh in terms of human life would it have
been better just to withdraw all
together is that a fair yes the the inva
is it still work the invasion of
cambodia the the extended time of the
u.s soldiers certainly sick later 69 70
sustained a lot of casualties should we
have perhaps we should have just
withdrawn um dispensed with honor thank
you
uh
if you look at the american
political
debate there was no one
if you look at the
position of the democratic party
at that time
you will find
that
nobody in 1969
and 70
recommended unilateral
withdrawal
that the position
of the johnson administration was
that
vietnamese troops had to withdraw first
and
six months after that
uh american withdrawals would start
so
a unilateral withdrawal of american
forces
in the middle of a war
declaring we cannot stand
the consequences of this war
i don't know anybody who recommended it
at that time
then by two years later we were talking
about
uh increments
of withdrawal and very relatively
few casualties
in
retrospect
towards the war words all these
casualties
but of course if you lose a war
you cannot say
but what it achieved in any event
was that the
uh
that the uh
that southeast asia
was
not overrun
and it probably made a contributing
factor
to the opening
to the opening
to china
but it was a better ending
i do not blame you or any administration
perhaps the fault is not in the stars
but in all of ourselves
thank you what did you say uh just a
statement dr kissinger uh this is the
last question on uh on the right here
thank you um hello dr kissinger it's a
pleasure to hear you speak this evening
i've always been a fan of yours finding
fascinating i may not agree with you
always but you're an interesting
individual and influence our world in
many ways um the war on drugs was issued
under nixon and
the long term of it we have more people
in prison in china 70 percent of our
prisoners are not violent do you think
the war on drugs was worth it and you
think it should be continued into the
21st century and you think we should
continue it or look at it as a failure
or was it a victory what do you think of
that
like war on drugs and how it's affected
in the last 40 some odd years
the war on drugs uh the domestic
policy matter related affects people
yeah i was under nixon
i
i don't think any statement i can make
on the war of drugs fair enough
will be
significant
but i want to make one other point here
my observations are directed at an
american at the american audience
i have great sympathy for the vietnamese
who are in this audience
and of course
their perspective
has to be
has to be different
and i'm sorry
not because of any action
the administration in which i uh
i was involved in
but it i
it is a historic tragedy
that america found itself so divided
and could not solve its domestic
debates
so that it could
come out of the war
with a result
that was more compatible
with what on a bipartisan basis
it had entered
and that's a legend uh we should learn
dr kisser do you have made your mark on
history
what will history say about henry
kissinger
all right uh
[Music]
i have
i have no obsession about this i had
the good fortune of being
able to come to the united states
when
most of the many of the people we do
might grow up
were killed in
germany
so i've always been deeply grateful to
this country
and i know what it represents
to
the peace
in the world
i've been lucky
in being able
to execute my
concerns
as my profession
and so i'm
i i'm not involved in what i'm doing
in order to get
history
written about me
there is an
extensive record
and some people
and it will be judged
although i must say the way
the mass of material that is produced
now
in the internet
age you i'm not too sure whether you can
say his dream will come to
a fair judgment anyway
that is not my concern i try to do the
best i could
and that's all i can say
so anyone
we are
we are not only grateful to you uh dr
history for being our honored guest
tonight but for serving your country
uh as a
as a uh
in world war ii we have many veterans
out there including yourself and i would
ask now that you stand and be recognized
by this audience please
thank you for your service
dr kissinger thank you so much for your
time tonight thank you all
[Music]
uh
[Music]